she's singing to her
she's singing to the girl that gets all
the guys please don't take my guy away
from me there it is
that's what it's really all about and by
the way if you just joined us right now
we're talking
yeah i just found out that adam's a die
hard dolly parton fan
yeah so if you ever thought he was a soy
boy he's definitely not
uh soy boy how did you feel about
everybody missing you about to do it for
like a couple days
i appreciate the love it was nothing but
love in the comment section it was
really it was somewhat
there was some love and there was some
extra love if you know what i mean thank
you for not firing me according to uh
everyone here though you know if i'm
gonna come to some of these people's
jobs be like
fire bill right now get him out of here
show up at his job but dolly parton
she's got a great uh
sing it jolene jolene jolene
how can you not love dolly i bet gavin
newsom doesn't love her though i mean we
were just hating on her i love
hating on dolly you said she looked
rough in 1912 that was a comment on the
on the playboy cover pull it pull it up
kai can you pull up the playboy cover
that tom didn't like can you pull it up
i think it's important quite the phrase
when you're talking about the playboy
cover
yeah pulled that uh but did either one
of you guys subscribe to playboy before
or no
you don't like yes would you honestly
yes or no
would i no were you a subscriber yeah at
one point yeah i won't
i was too yeah in the 90s there's
nothing wrong with that what's wrong
with this cover by the way you know what
it is
i scanned it yesterday and i think the
hair through me threw you off
it will be off that's all everyone's
hair looked in the 70s did it not
but what's crazy is isn't it crazy that
after she gave the million dollars the
whole conversation about dolly parton
she gives the million dollars
to uh uh to modernize yes correct and
then next thing you know playboy comes
back saying i know you're about to turn
75 are you willing to do another
cover they offered it to her they
offered it to be on the cover of playboy
magazine you know it's brilliant we've
been talking about playboy how they're
trying to reboot themselves but
that's some smart pr marketing right
there they capitalized at the right time
but
and by the way playboy right now is for
sale i don't know if you guys know that
they're for sale they're wanting someone
to buy them
and i think the right person needs to
buy we've talked about this before
already but anyways let's get right into
the podcast let's do it you're doing
okay have you been okay
we're doing fine yes everything's great
good to be back yeah you can see
everybody
yes we had i i got to tell you for all
the
people out there we got some hilarious
people in the comment section
they're like man adam looks rough today
when steve shout he's like adam aids for
30 years i said yeah man by the way why
don't we start off by giving you some if
you sincerely miss adam
press thumbs up if you seriously don't
miss them at all put thumbs down
okay we're going to cancel the show it's
over it's over can psyche handle this
good fix if there's anybody that's going
to do fine adam's going to be excited
okay we got a lot of things we've
covered ten thousand thumbs up thanks
everybody
we got ten thousand thumbs up shut down
you guys i love you guys we got we got a
lot of things to cover
mario's in the house marty how are you
mario got a brand new car he got a brand
new
uh uh uh uh dodge uh charger
challenger ridiculous redwood black
wheels that he's uh
six speeding tickets already but aside
from that it's a very nice car
okay so here's the topics we got the
topics we got the topics we got today
amazon enters the healthcare
industry and puts it on notice with its
latest push into pharmacy okay that's
gonna be pretty intense we got a lot to
talk about there
apple slashes app store fees for smaller
developers which is insane
insane to think about what they're doing
that's very important to think about
because
a lot of people are worried about
anything you buy on apple anything
you buy on apple from the app any app on
app store
that you buy a product they keep thirty
percent they slashed it to 15
which is a big deal we'll talk about
that elon musk is now the third richest
man in the world he's made a lot of
money i'm sure
adam's going to give us an update about
how much money he's made this year alone
ridiculous
it is ridiculous kai added this story in
here for whatever reason but we'll just
announce it norwegian files airlines
files for bankruptcy
no that's right so we're going to talk
about that we're going to talk about
that
i'm zinger home depot and lowe's are
standout winners of the pandemic we'll
tell you why
and the coveted economy laid off
employees are becoming entrepreneurs
we'll talk about that as well
airbnb goes ipo walmart beats analyst
expectation as online order
orders surges 79 revenues jumped to 134
billion dollars
in a quarter bitcoin approaches all-time
high elon musk is joining the s p
500 uh then you have politicians we got
to talk about governor newsom what he
did recently on the hot city coming out
he had to apologize
and then yesterday did you see what
happened with cuomo yesterday in new
york with the whole obnoxious question
yeah did you see that one or no did you
actually see this channel
yeah we'll show that as well but he's
just kind of like what an obnoxious
question to ask with this and anyways
we'll cover that and de blasio came out
a couple seconds later and
defended him or not no no and and
basically gave the stay at home
like everybody's staying home yeah we'll
talk about that that's pathetic what's
going on in those two states i mean you
got to love those two states
florida and texas are loving those two
states or maybe not a lot of people in
florida and texas are worried about the
politics
may switch because people are coming in
trump pulls troops from afghanistan
adam's very much of a fan of that
trump was supposed to go after nuclear
sites we'll talk about that nancy pelosi
policing with house stamps we've talked
about that already
uh moderna with an efficacy of 94 and a
half percent
and then pfizer comes out a week later
saying oh we're not at 90
we're at 95 i'm curious to know what you
guys think about that bezos gives 800
million
donations to climate change we just talk
about dolly parton and we have to cover
the james harden story
why these guys want to be pre-traded we
just have to cover the james harden
story but why don't we start off with
app
uh apple slashes app store fees for
smaller developers
sure tech giant cuts its take from fit
from 30
to 15 for some app makers and a wake up
criticism over its power
in the apple device ecosystem starting
next year the iphone maker said
wednesday it will collect
fifteen percent rather than thirty
percent app store sales from companies
that generate no more than one million
dollars in revenue through the software
platform
including in-app purchases the field
will remain thirty percent for
developers who sales
through the app stores excluding
commission's payments exceed one million
so this is for folks that are below a
million meaning the reduction won't
affect such
vocal apple opponents as video game
company epic games
fy like aka fortnite right
yeah which we talked about that before
apple's 30 takes
has uh been at the heart of complaints
this year from other tech companies and
some other users
over how it manages the vast digital
world of people who uses
iphone ipads pretty much they're you
know a monopoly there with this world
but
what are your thoughts about what apples
would go from 30 to 15. this is
something that we covered
a few months ago when fortnite came out
with that uh not fortnite epic games the
owner of fortnite came out with that
sick commercial kai i don't know if you
want to pull that up where they
basically
used apple's infamous commercial from
1984.
commercial sick commercial to take a
shot at them took a ridiculous shout out
basically
put this whole story on the map yeah i
mean we weren't talking about the story
prior to that
they put the story on the map now since
then we've seen uh
tim apple aka tim cook have to show up
in front of congress as well as jack
dorsey and mark zuckerberg and
especially big tech in congress and now
basically what apple did was says you
know what
here's the commercial um and then the
guy throws the
the unicorn shaped um of fortnite at
apple yeah that's a brilliant move
that's what i mean essentially what
they've been accused of is the
the big the app store monopoly right so
they're monopolizing
you know uh these developers that are
coming on the website are on the on the
app store now
obviously there's been big tech
regulation we've seen this happen
everyone in congress um but what i think
they've done is essentially let me read
this for you viewers that haven't seen
this epic games has defied the app store
monopoly in retaliation apple is
blocking fortnite from a billion devices
joined the fight to stop 2020 from
becoming 1984.
very phenomenal are they still not on
the app store
they're still not on the app store wow
okay yeah they're still not on the app
store clearly a sick commercial
clearly spawned just everyone being like
all right what the hell is going on here
so what i think apple did here was sort
of
say all right we're getting a lot of
hate we're getting a lot of uh haters
out there
so let's self-regulate before congress
or anyone steps in
so i've got some numbers for you so in
worldwide commerce worldwide commerce
apple generated 519
billion dollars 85 of that went to
third parties right so they generated 54
billion in revenue but here what i
thought was interesting
is there's the the number here is one
million so if you make
less than one million in revenue um
you know they charge you 15 if you make
more than a million do you know what
percentage
of apps on the app store generate more
than 1 million
what percentage yes i'd say 90 yeah a
high high percentage okay
um 0.2 percent wait stay down
ask the question what percentage of apps
on the app store generate
more than one million dollars what
percentage generates more than a million
dollars is only point two percent
that's according to an austrian journal
yes what percentage of
apps yeah yes yes the question is what
percentage of revenues
comes to them from those less than a
million dollars so that's the real
question
because there's a lot of ghetto there
you go 92 percent here's the number
exactly
92 of apple's revenue comes from
these companies that make more than a
million dollars yep 0.2
not 2 0.2 um comes from
apps that generate more than a million
dollars there's 1.
1.8 million apps on the app store yeah
but that's and a small small small
percentage of it is essentially
generating
more than a million dollars that's all
that's all it is so basically yeah
the big dogs who are sp are making all
the money the big dogs they're going to
continue to pay
they're not affected they're going to
have to pay they're going to be fine and
then all the small little apps which are
essentially
1.7999 of the 1.8 million apps
are going to pay 15 you got something on
that's like this here's what it is
it's a good data right there by the way
it's a slum lord lowering rent on
low-income housing
that's all it is he's not touching the
rent on the penthouse why do you have to
you don't have to right three things
that apple isn't known for
being charitable being stupid and losing
money
okay so clearly there's a pr move this
is all it is
because the average person is going to
think oh wow apple's thinking about me
the little guy but it's a math problem
that's all it is
they're not nothing's changed as far as
their revenue let me tell you what my
concern is i'm gonna tell you what my
concern is here's what my biggest
concern is i'm being very sincere about
this
everybody knows i'm an apple guy okay we
got you we got an apple yesterday right
everything to us is apple we love apple
there's apple there there's apple here
there's apple here
this isn't an apple commercial though no
no this is not an apple commercial what
i'm trying to say is i'm a pro
apple guy but i'm going to tell you what
scares the hell out of me with this
so think about what uh
twitter and facebook so twitter perfect
example with toy we haven't even talked
about this by the way it's not even on
the story i don't know why we didn't add
it to the story
jack dorsey comes out and says what we
made a mistake we should have let that
new york
historic story go well they knew if they
would have posted allowed that story to
go
that would have gotten a few hundred
million views that day right if they
would have let that story go
but now he says what i apologize we did
the wrong thing a week after election
okay a week after election he says that
the power
these big corporations are starting to
have is a little too much
a little too much and i'm all capitalism
but watch what happens here
here's my biggest concern apple comes
out with the iphone 12
right i got it it's the 512 i'm gonna
give away nine of these right now got it
that's it
it's the brand new looking at it right
there this is the brand new one we get a
look here let me get a look
this is the brand well you got to take
it out to see what it looks like with
the new iphone if you take the thing out
just to kind of see what they did to the
body because that's what the difference
is
okay if you take this out if i can't
take it out i've been i've got to hit
the weights a little bit more lately man
this is
so they went back to the old oh have an
earphone but look at the
what it is is the round thing is gone
and you know by the way it still breaks
paul bought it the next day he broke it
so it still breaks so if you drop it
you're still going to break your shout
out to paulo scarcely got for breaking
his new iphone
um but the point with this is
my concern is where's blackberry where's
droid
where's the google phone there is no
competition look what's happened here
if i wanted i'm like hey can you get
your phone i'm doing airdrop oh i'm
droid bro can you get on
iphone you have to get an iphone i can't
do airdrop to you
i send a text i put a thumbs up on it
you ever done a thumbs up for somebody
that has droid it comes back and message
wasn't received
why not it happens to eric all the time
that's one message it comes up screaming
you know
throw up everything you want to facetime
a droid you can't do it
there are you want to do an itunes
download you can do you want to go
to a movie you do shazam shazam takes
you to itunes
everything goes to all roads lead
to apple which is absolutely scary
because if apple doesn't like
you and they decide to take a fortnight
out they can afford to do that
and there's nothing you can say about it
why because it's in a place like this
where capitalism needs some work meaning
you apple's getting to the point of
monopoly apple's getting to the point of
control and this is where somebody's got
to get involved because
there is no choices so any they can do
anything they want to do today they can
get away with murder today if they
wanted to
because we don't have that many choices
so my biggest concern isn't the fact
that they're saying
you know good for them if it's like
being progressive tax is what they're
doing the more money you make the more
taxes you pay
so they just came up with a new
progressive tax to say the smaller
earners
pay less taxes and quite frankly if
you're making a million
say you're doing 900 000 in apps you
were paying 30
which is what 270. now you're going to
pay 15 which is what
135. that additional 135 goes to you
what does that 135 pay you
either three employees or an additional
135 in your pocket it's a good amount
for people doing less than a million
dollars
but it's not going to do anything to
their revenues at the top so
my only concern apple's getting a little
too strong you know if you're going to
be a monopoly like an apple potentially
you better have the best product so
thank god they do at least for that no
and the other thing that you'd be
concerned with the monopoly is the
pricing but at least the iphone 12 came
down a little right
so and the other right is in the iphone
12 there was it was a decent price
compared to the 11
wasn't that part of the story i mean
this was still 1500 bucks so but this is
a 512. so i don't know
if it's still if it's gone down or not
you know and then
apple right now has twitter and facebook
running cover for them because
congress is more concerned about their
censorship and the things that they're
doing
with the social media as opposed to
apple they might be able to get away
with forming a monopoly where the
justice department won't be looking at
them because they have bigger fish to
fry in silicon valley with these other
clients you know you know how they say
what comes first the chicken or the egg
okay who needs who more
google needs is it google is it apple
is it amazon or is it uh what's the
other one is it
facebook facebook who needs who more so
apple facebook amazon
or google which comes first most people
are getting
all that stuff from their phone so you
would say that apple
is the you have to be keeper that is so
dangerous for everything else you have
to understand i'm going to get something
on
amazon
what i'm trying what i'm trying to say
to you that's what's scary by the way
google pays
apple 13 billion dollars every year to
be on their phone
google pays apple 13 bill just to check
hey apple did you know that 13 billion
and maybe higher right now yeah
does that include for chrome for being
on they pay 13 billion just for
their chrome for their stuff to be on
there 13 billion guess what apple's
going to do every year
15 billion 20 billion guess what no no
let's negotiate no
20 billion right you can't say nothing
because the chicken or the egg that that
apple is but you know what that's so
much better than safari they have to
keep having chrome
on there i don't like safari i don't
know if i disagree with you but i don't
think the answer is they have to
nothing with apple right now they have
to but the fact that they're doing
this i think this is a sign in the right
direction the fact that they're doing
this this is a little bit of a sign in
the right direction the fact that
they're going from 30 to 15
you can't all of a sudden go say
somebody's giving you a billion dollars
of revenue oh we're going to go to 15
i'm going to get now half a billion
dollars who the hell is going to do that
but the fact that they're doing this
they're trying to get the small
developers to still want to come and
build apps on their
on their platform which i don't know but
i'm telling you guys right now apple's
getting a little too so people are
worried about amazon
all roads lead to apple but doesn't this
further your argument a little bit about
the monopolization of this company
because
yeah by lowering that they're going to
attract everybody why wouldn't you go to
apple if you were somewhere else
but but you mean if you're an apple
developer yeah you're going there let
if you're watching this right now i'm
actually curious to know how many guys
don't use an apple phone i don't care
what phone it is just say
i don't use an iphone and what kind of
phone it is you use just type it below
and say i don't use an apple phone i use
samsung i use droid i use what else is
there droid samsung google
uh uh what is it lg huawei lg
i'm cute what is the second best one in
the world right now is it drawing
that was essentially my question is we
talked about the monopoly here
if you're not using apple what are you
using what are you using over there
mario
apple okay if you're not using apple
what are you using so i'm glad you asked
that question and then my second
question would be on tax
is this gonna be and i don't know if we
have this answer but something we can
maybe uncover
is is the is this 15 versus 30
is that gonna be a marginal tax bracket
meaning if you pay
if you make 1.1 million dollars is your
first
million taxed at 15 percent yeah then
your next hundred thousand that's what
they tax at 30
they're not going to bump you up of
course that's what they're going to do
they're going to have to go your first
million at 30 million and then you're
going to they didn't do that
shady system they wouldn't they would
get so much backlash if they do it in
that way kai what are your thoughts on
that man that marginal tax bracket
he learned about that the other day yeah
he asked why would i want to make more
money if i pay more in taxes you know
norwegians don't know what guacamole is
hey you know what happened do you guys
not miss the flip phone
because don't you need a dramatic way to
end a conversation you can't do that
anymore tapping the off button is nice
clapping by the way i had the netflix i
should do it so hard that i would break
it mine was always the one that would
hang up do you know what i'm talking
about
why not many people pissed you off every
day you were a lot more aggressive
back then oh that was the thing you did
not even want to know but okay here we
go this is what people are saying by the
way
a lot of people apparently don't use it
okay samsung google pixel
um uh let's see here i don't uh
xiaomi xiaomi xiaomi i don't know what
that's android samsung
samsung samsung's i use an android
huawei
uh android samsung samsung galaxy 20.
apple is virus free xiaomi what is yummy
by the way i use xiaomi
x-i-a-m-o-i have you heard of i had that
phone
can you pull it up i have no idea what
that is one guy is stuck here in 1998.
he says you use
aol instant messenger good luck with
that guy i think he's going to go to
expert
x-i a o-m-i what is this
click on it's a chinese brand wow
okay it's like a huawei put click on
images
yeah i've never heard of this this is
great i mean i love seeing competition
there's lots of
samsung uh uh apple sucks
okay good i like seeing that i like
people saying apple sucks i hope you
stay to that
and i hope android so there's got to be
some competition i'm hoping android is
not sitting there behind closer saying
guys we can't compete with these guys
it's over
i'm hoping they're not saying it's over
and they're probably not right i mean as
big as they are i
i don't know about that because i'm not
seeing it by the way if you're watching
this
do you think a another competitor is
going to come and give apple a run for
their money if yes
put thumbs up if no thumbs down this
could have a lot of thumbs down with
this one if you think they are put
thumbs up if you don't think put thumbs
down
what's it gonna change by the way people
actually miss you people actually
missing thank you guys people
love you i was surprised what's it gonna
take for you to get back to your old
blackberry days
if blackberry does something creative it
would be but
at this point the business model of
phone if you want to compete with apple
you have to do one thing
you can't just say let's build a better
phone than this that's not going to work
we have to build a better net what do i
need
so think about it this way what do you
use the most like microsoft word do you
use that a lot what do you use a lot use
microsoft outlook use
microsoft what things do you use that's
a form of a net
yeah do you use google email google
drive
what do you mean i think i think
google's the greatest invention in the
history of mankind i mean gmail
and the search engine i don't know how
you could possibly live without it
okay so but google has to go more than
that it's got to be music it's got to be
movies like
it's got to be something more than that
i don't like if amazon came out and
their app
is linked to amazon and movies and if
you bought amazon's phone
and then apple has too big of a head
start there's no way because of app
store because of their their uh
uh this is this is by the way this is
creating content i mean look you buy the
the phone's been the same phone for a
long time they just keep
adding more cameras to the back it's
like oh we got more cameras and it's
faster every time and i buy it yeah like
okay i'm a loyal
so i keep buying but what about the 5g
can you tell a huge difference yes speed
is insane
this is 5g yeah speed is insane i'm not
going to lie to you it's so
fast and i to me i i feel the speed it's
very good what was the first year you
had an apple phone
an iphone i never i said i'm the guy
that said i would never flip to an
iphone until this one guy came to my
office
i remember his name here in a minute he
came to my office and says let me tell
you
10 minutes why i need to own an iphone
and i said okay tell me so i was trying
to do business with he says here's why
boom boom boom boom boom boom boom boom
i said man he's just got a great
argument what year was that this was in
no 2007 okay right that's my point it's
only 2008. it's only been 12 13 years so
since i'm an apple guy yeah it hasn't
been decades and decades and now
what was your first year that's a
quarter of my life you know listen i had
an apple
i had an apple macbook in 1995.
so i've had the computer since the
mid-90s i i had a blind
iphone though the iphone i didn't want
to switch i used to be a blackberry guy
and i was afraid
i just thought i'd never pick it up and
it took like one day uh 2012 probably
2012. i don't know 2010. i'm losing my
memory i don't know
10 years ago something like that yeah
okay all right i remember with the with
the switch was occurring in in
the late two you know 2007 2008-ish
you had friends started popping up with
iphones like oh check this out i'm like
buddy blackberry what are you talking
about and then
by the way people rest in peace people
don't think
there's going to be competition for
apple did you notice that people don't
think there's going to be i agree with
them
i think it's too tough wow they'll
squash them i trust capitalism i just
think the government's got to get
involved here to say hey you guys got a
monopoly we got to break it apart they
got to get involved here this is
the government the only way you could
break it apart remember what i'm not a
fan of like people
think i'm a fan of i'm not a fan of
bullies okay
the moment a company becomes too big of
a bully not a fan of that
i don't mind bullying bullies but i have
a problem when the bully is bullying the
little guy i don't like that when that's
what's taking place right
so right now you know apple can kind of
uh go out there and bully a lot of
people
who's the bully apple are you i'm not
questioning that i'm saying
even questioning what i find humorous is
that apple was the little startup yeah
that could you know but they're now
so big well david versus glide sometimes
david becomes goliath well exactly
that's my point
about it but they have the mindset of it
david that's why they keep growing
they think like a david they still think
they're nobody they still think they're
the small guy they saw awesome
but they're playing the offense in a way
that's the gain
the game is uh being won by them so look
there's crony capitalism that makes
capitalism look bad
there's monopoly that makes capitalism
look bad okay and this is one of those
situations this is not crony capitalism
this is a monopoly
you know what i think a huge asset for
apple is i think tim cook is likable
he doesn't come across as a bully yeah i
mean they're front and center seats
jobs dude oh totally not some cool they
took pride in it as well but here's book
is the opposite you're right here's a
guy that
disagrees with 95 of trump's policies
and he goes and works with trump i don't
know anybody on that side
he just goes and says hey would you like
to help us launch the new mac well yeah
sure trump goes
i'd like to come and help the government
out i'd like to come because he let's
sit down and talk
how do you do you got a real strategic
thinker yeah what do you say
what does he want to go to war with the
president united states it's called
setting aside your emotions buddy that's
right that's not it's called setting
your side
oh really okay you want to go there
let's go there okay let's go
zuckerberg all the time
this leads me to houston rockets which
that's
a trillion dollars all right all right
the the league the lead sure the leak is
what i'm talking about
the league so the nba has something
going on this year
which was they came out and they said
blm black lives matter the floor
everything right everything about the
nba with social justice this is not fair
all
and everybody except for one person
followed suit and who was that one
person from orlando jonathan isaac
jonathan
he broke his knee yeah but here's the
thing but he wasn't a starter he wasn't
a star nobody even knew who he was
i've just called him that week for that
week he became the number one
new jersey yeah behind lebron number two
number two
yeah so for like three days so look what
happens with the rockets so james harden
says i want to trade
i was like why is james harden wanting
to trade this guy's being offered 50
million a year
he wants a trade what do you mean you
want to trade okay so westbrook wants to
trade westbrook wants to leave and all
this other stuff right i know you
probably got some insight on this here
so yeah you know the you use the
situation is these guys want to go play
with durant
westbrook wants to go play with this guy
is that really what the case was
for the last week or so hardness
expressed concerns behind the scenes
regarding the future the rockets as he
believes the team's window for competing
for championship has closed
after last season the 31 euro guard is
ready to join another team of superstar
for a chance of winning a ring
at this point he's looking at the nets
and a couple other teams right according
to the ringer's kevin o'connor rockets
owner tillman fertitta
specifically doesn't like the idea of
trading for harden for money
will tillman fertitta trade james to
daryl mori i've been told probably not
o'connor reports i think
maury would offer way more than just ben
simmons i've still
been told unlikely that fertitta
wouldn't trade him for maury now watch
this
behind closed door story comes out this
week about why this is really taking
place
tom why don't you tell us what that
story is okay so adrian wojnovsky for
espn
um who's pretty biased in his reporting
anyway but he's always right when it
comes to the nba the guy knows what's up
he's dialed in
so he said that there's a mini revolt
going on inside the houston locker room
right now because
hardin westbrook the two leaders of that
team uh were so upset that tillman
fertitta who owns the
lowry's the big restaurant mastros you
know the big restaurant chain hotels
um that he was a supporter of donald
trump so there was an open revolt in the
locker room they don't want to play for
him anymore
and you know what i guarantee you
tillman fertitta doesn't give a damn
about that he'll probably not trade him
because of that he doesn't care
he's not going to bow to him by the way
james harden says the window for
winning a championship is closing for
him no kidding you play with russell
westbrook how are you going to win
anything with him
the reason he wants to go to brooklyn in
my opinion sure to play for kevin durant
but who's the assistant coach down in
brooklyn it's mike d'antoni
steve nash hired him so his style of
ball
only works in a few ways but this is a
huge deal this is
huge because what kind of precedent does
that send
if a star player refute an employee of a
company
refuses to work because he doesn't agree
with the owner's political choices
isn't this still a free country my god i
hope tillman for cheetah does not bow
down to this at
all yeah i look houston rockings has
been a sinking ship
since basically they went all in to
trade chris paul
for russell westbrook they basically
traded away anyone over six seven and
they were just playing small ball lineup
it clearly didn't work
dara mori left tillman fertitta
obviously has been owning the team for a
few years now
for me this is the first i'm really
hearing that tillman fertitta is a big
trump supporter and that's the the guy
who reported it
is a big blm guy and he is a great
reporter well everyone's a blm guy
in the nba you're right that's not yeah
that's not like this one come out and
say that this is not an inaccurate
reporting by him i think at the end of
the day the houston rockets are sinking
ship
no no wait wait these are two different
things here these are two different
things
the report is they don't want to play
for a guy that's pro-trump
that's the republican you know how many
owners in the nba are pro-trump no say a
good majority
no no no no no okay yeah okay fair so
like you're going to get traded to a
team that's well wait a minute
but go there go there what is the
consequences of doing that
go there the whole idea of saying you
know i don't want to play for dan
gilbert because he's pro-trump right
cleveland cavaliers so lebron leaves
yeah okay now let's put the
tillman frittata is is what it's for
like what
how do you say his name is for uh what
do you call it for
trump so you got gilbert you got him no
cuba
yeah okay there's a few other guys of
course so let's just say that spreads
and that becomes a cultural thing in the
nba that we don't play for those seven
owners
and everybody behind me i'm just saying
i don't think it's i don't think number
one trump's on his way out the door so
but that's not the point it's not the
point that players have been dictating
what they want to be doing in the nba
for years now this isn't a breaking news
it is breaking news about the trump
people no no no no
how we got to the story let me explain
to you how we got to the story okay we
started off the first
story was dolly parton we went right off
right off the bat because his
subscription to playboy then then we
went to
we went to uh uh apple slashes at prices
right
and this led to houston why did this
lead to the houston story here's why
because i made the point that i have
so much respect i re i tweeted something
about the
tim cook and he retweeted it or he liked
the post and commented on it
and i said i have so much respect for a
man that disagrees with 95
of what the president does he's still
willing to set aside his emotions to go
out and sit down and talk to him
that is the ultimate respect i don't
have to agree
with tim cook i don't have to agree with
the way tim cook lives i don't have to
agree he's the first fortune 100 company
ceo that comes out saying i'm gay
i have no i have i don't have to agree
with anything the guy says
but the way he handled it in the nba
they're not handling it that way now
what the nba is saying is your what oh
apps oust that guy spread it nobody
wants to play for the
rockets and this this is if i'm the nba
commissioner adam silver i must say
something here
i would be very careful with taking the
league in that direction
our company everybody knows where i'm at
politically when it comes down to
capitalism socially people don't know
where i'm at socially because you know i
could be all over the place with
socially
but politically in our company when it
comes down to economically everyone
knows what i'm
i'm a capitalist at the highest level
right one of my guys is a die hard obama
fan
die hard obama fan i went to the
bookstore the other day
and i saw an obama thing and i said man
this guy's going to love it
i bought it i shipped it to him he's
like i can't believe you sent it to me
like dude you and i have
been going back 15 years i'm looking for
an obama autograph for this guy to send
to him
as a gift ricky aguilar
[Music]
but but let me tell you what i mean by
that i'm going to send him this obama
thing he doesn't even know it's going to
go to him right
why am i doing this because to him
that's a zero no problem
i didn't agree with the affordable
health care act i didn't the
nba has to be thinking about that
there's nothing wrong with having
republicans
independents and democrats if they go in
this direction it's going to be
problematic
the nfl on the other hand they're okay
where you want to be no problem no one
gets ousted
you want to go play before that's your
calling
once you say pigs and you have that and
you go to miami
and you support a chavez with cuban
community you deserve to be ousted
if you say something like that to the
cuban community that's an insult to what
that meant to the cuban community do you
know
do you know how emotional it is for
somebody like me who escaped around to
come here because of what
jimmy carter did to iran i should be in
iran right now but i'm here because of
what he did to him when you mentioned
jimmy carter i feel it
i feel what carter did to iran when they
had that meeting with the four big
empires germany france uk
and uh uh carter and saying hey the 25
year old contract in iran's coming up
in 1975 we got to figure out a way to
get this guy the hell out of there so we
don't have to get the spike
of oil prices and boom what happens to
iran khomeini comes who has no clout to
run a country
and next thing you know couple years
later all the military gets killed the
2000 generals
they get rid of war 500 000 people died
just because
carter said and all these other guys
said we can't do the 25-year contract
again with oil
yes cuba feels it so when you're a
football player you come in you wear
something like that
that's not even something to joke about
by the way people love their countries
people love where they were born i love
where i was born my emotions goes over
there people from cuba you want to come
and play something like that
i wouldn't tolerate it except i would
have suspended him i wouldn't have sat
there and said oh talking about
kaepernick
would have been suspended for the season
what the hell are you wearing over here
we wear socks with pigs on it
not just the pigs to say something about
the cuban community with the uh
when he wore uh the shirt uh with the
shirt that he wear when he was going
there
uh the cubans were furious when this
took place yeah
i mean this is you don't disrupt and you
do it in miami
you do it in miami so that's a
completely different conversation when
you're going with kaepernick
bring this back to you i don't have a
problem with i don't have a problem with
what kaepernick was talking about
about the first time he came up and
talked about it i think the mistake on
there was roger goodell
took a year and a half to go talk to the
guy yeah nobody immediately you should
have met with them
but in this situation you mean to tell
me you cannot be a republican in the nba
oh that's problematic short term it may
look good long term they're going to pay
price for it
guaranteed they're already starting to
pay the price for it i guarantee you
that adam silver knows that his brand
has been
devalued i watched the nba draft last
night it was boring as hell
seriously it was nothing there was no
juice nothing i only recognized like
three players
yes it has hurt the nba by the way i'm
sending tillman fertitta
uh no more mr nice guy book all right i
want him to handle this situation with
harden with an iron fist he's gonna get
after it
now look at hard i mean these players
are they have too much power this is
insane
look what the ramifications of this
james harden is saying
i want to leave texas where i'm going to
get a 120 million dollar extension
with no state income tax and go to
brooklyn new york and pay 15
so right off the top that's about 20
million dollars the other thing too
is the agents the agents are empowering
these athletes to a degree that we've
never seen before
and it's the same thing in hollywood
william morris caa
icm they they are so political i mean
they will
fire you as a client if you had one
tweet about
something positive positive about a
republican five years ago
so this is i guarantee you this is the
number one problem for adam silver
he is in contact with fertitta every day
saying do not
budge on this let him sit in houston
they're going to stink this year
kai pull up that article right there
with washington post on what he did you
need to see this apparently both of you
guys missed it on what he did
after a game at miami he's wearing a
shirt with castro on it and saying good
things about him
in an interview in an interview i would
have suspended him for the season
look at this guy colin kaepernick
grilled by miami herald over fidel
castro's shirt go up a little bit
okay fidel castro shirt uh uh with the
49ers visit miami dolphins this week san
francisco column cabin engaged in the
conference called members of south
florida media how will one reporter want
to discuss something that happened in
august when kaepernick wore a shirt that
prepared
appeared to show support for fidel
castro which led to tense exchange
the shirt depicted the scenes from a
1960 meeting between castro malcolm x
and bohr
the phrase like minds think alike like
mind think alike seriously kaepernick
war
to a news conference after the 49ers
third preseason game which was when his
refusal to stand during the national
anthem became a major story
and if you go a little lower he said
something about the willingness to be
open-minded
and he had a couple comments i'm not
talking about fidel castro
and his oppression i'm talking about
malcolm x and what he's done for people
you're not saying that you you
you wore that in miami one thing that
fidel castro did is they have the
highest literacy rate
because they invest more in their
education system than they did in their
prison system
which we do not do here even though
we're fully capable that
what i know that what i mean
so so so a lot of this a lot of these
comments from people who are
coming out here trying to seem political
and diplomatic fine you want to say what
you want to say there's consequences as
well well i agree with you
two things because again this is why i
respect tim cook okay this is why
a gay man who's a ceo of a fortune 100
fortune one company is the second order
largest company who is a gay man out of
san francisco
who disagrees with everything the man at
the white house stands for except for
five percent that has to do with economy
he's willing to set aside his beliefs
and say yeah let's figure out a way to
do business together
he ought to get the business man or the
he ought to get an award
whatever the award is you know how the
sports give awards for somebody that's
you know you do the most uh
charity stuff on the side there needs to
be an edification of how this guy's able
to set aside his political agenda
and sit with possibly the most
controversial president
in our lifetime trump and say let's
figure out something else yeah it'd be
inspiring for people
and we cannot do an award right that's
what they do like a nobel peace prize
but for
business 100 100 are you kidding me
i would have his picture and we have an
idea for the new creative meeting there
we go
this is this is kai put that down
write it down the other thing about tim
cook he grew up in alabama with probably
some values right i mean and he's kept
to his core
kaepernick also grew up in the right
place with some values how he turned out
to be this way is ridiculous but uh
that's a whole different story if you
get a picture of kaepernick like that
the last thing i want my quarterback
doing is thinking about political
statements did you spend enough time on
the playbook that week
you know you're so concerned about what
shirt you're wearing what hat matches it
to have a political social security i'm
all for something inspiring you
i am all for it like god knows i look
forward to my guys being inspired by
something right
one of my guys is cuban and puerto rican
so guess what he did he went to cuba he
came back i'm like let me see if this
thing's gonna
this thing's gonna like catch fire and
it's gonna do something to him or not
he came back he started saying let me
tell you what it's like in cuba i went
out there and i was looking at the
business like okay
i'm listening okay good good good by the
way he just crossed a million dollar
income we're paying him net million
dollars his business to 20 million last
12 months
george palaho just crossed a million
dollars yesterday or two days ago at 33
years old
34 years old he started with me at 18
years old all over the place finally he
was able to stay focused now he crossed
a million congratulations to him
but he goes to cuba i'm like okay let me
see what's going to happen to this guy
matt zapala starts doing stuff with
marines and military and all this stuff
then he wears red every friday he wears
red for what
why do why why do they wear red shirt on
fridays that's for the
uh yeah if you pull up marines he wears
red because the pow i believe
uh a military red shirt friday right red
shirt friday
red on friday there you go red shirt for
military friday
where's okay go red shirt friday was it
remember
everyone deployed remember everyone
deployed red yeah so he wears a red on
friday and it's like you know that
became a movement people are saying you
know what that's pretty cool people are
wearing it
i love when something inspires you but
if it does inspire you
don't make ignorant comments without
doing your own research on it just
because you watch one movie i'm assuming
colin kaepernick sat one night and
watched a malcolm x movie with denzel
washington he was inspired
came out and said let me tell you what
happened with the movie i watched last
night
what you're talking about being inspired
is you you're separating what he did
with the kneeling
i don't mind that that's what i'm saying
you're celebrating that with the fidel
castro shirt yes
two totally different things because i
lived in miami i never even heard this
story so i'm like what are you talking
about it's pathetic
okay i agree with you on that there's a
lot of cubans that are probably upset
with that no way they're digging that
in miami or anyone that obviously i
would love to see him and mask without
running two bar together
oh my god can i ask you a capitalist
question sure what's going through james
harden's mind he has a 200 million
dollar contract with adidas right i mean
that's probably where he makes most his
money
the bigger stars make more money on
their shoe deal than they do in their
contract that's probably why it doesn't
he has a cavalier attitude about staying
in houston but how do you not
worry about turning off a lot of people
that will not buy your product because
of that i mean i i just can't figure
this out
why athletes right now have to be so
political i don't i don't think
i think nike showed the no one cares
when when they signed colin kaepernick
and they paid him that money that they
paid him and the next thing you know
nike stock went up the next thing they
were just gonna drop
when they did the commercial everyone
was loving it everybody thought it was
it dropped and it went up
no nike showed these guys don't worry
about it
we're fine we have our community right
that's what nike did i guess
but i'm but i'm telling you the
difference is here's a difference though
nike's customers don't care because
they're buying shoes they can't afford
but adam silver's customers
do care adam silver's customers are
those who can cut a check for 2.2
billion dollars
minimum those guys are going to care so
you have a league
with 100 of your owners being democrat
let's see how that league is going to do
let me say that one more time you go
ahead and own a league where 100
of your owners are democrats i would
never buy an nba team
i would buy an mlb team i would cons i
wouldn't i'm not an nfl guy to buy an
nfl but i would buy an mlb team
because mlp is a little bit more chill
hey do your thing it's cool you don't
like it all it's good they respect
everybody they're
and the values still getting i love that
i love the mlb culture
but in the mba side they don't care what
they're shooting because their customers
don't care
the customers of adam silver care yeah
you're not saying that all
100 of owners in the nba are democrat
you're making an example what i'm trying
to say
no no but here's what okay so let's just
say we the three of us own a team
right okay and we're all independent or
republican but we're not democrats
and we out of the 30-something owners in
the nba we have a call together we have
a secret meeting nobody knows
and i say adam how do you feel right now
about how things are going dude i got to
tell you i'm getting a lot of pressure
a lot of pressure how you feeling tom
it's a lot of pressure man i don't every
time i'm talking to mark cuban he's
saying this every time i'm talking to
you know balmer he's saying this every
time i'm talking to these guys like a
lot of pressure right now i'm kind of
being ousted and i'm hearing these guys
are talking against me
what do you guys want to do i don't know
i don't know
i mean i hang on to the business because
it's making money right now but i'm
telling you i'm thinking about putting
it for sale i'm thinking about putting
it for sale
if i'm in that community and i'm the
minority
why wouldn't adam silver listen to me
right now why wouldn't adam silver
defend me right now
adam silver is about the players he's
not about the owners he's not about the
league he's about the players that's
what he's all about
which is fine your number one product is
who it's players it's not owners owners
don't go out there and play
michael jordan said i don't see general
managers scoring any points i don't see
owners scoring any points
it's the players that win the games he's
right but you got to respect
the owners who have opposed your ideas
you cannot do that it's a dangerous
place to be
i got three points on this number one i
love the impersonation of adam silver on
the phone call where he says dude
that was good yeah can you imagine adam
silver using that word i mean this is
about as wide as you could get
um tillman for t you also missed my
little plug for
no more mr nice guy because you were
looking at colin kaepernick at the time
bottom line is look at the nba when they
continue to do this
the nba is going to be like new york and
california they're going to be they're
going to be
falling off the deep end of a cliff
pretty soon if they don't get off this
socialist stance that they're on
because people are getting socialist
social justice right
one in the same i don't know one in the
same tom
they both have the word social in it
does your mom get social security i
assume she does
so i mean let's go i mean social justice
and socialism are not the same
point my point here was very simple guys
the whole point
about everything we talked about is
freaking salute
to tim cook and trump for being able to
get along
that's the salute they don't like each
other's policies
they figured out a way to get along
because they found something in common
what's the one thing the one thing in
common is
hey let's help the economy there's
nothing you say it in a way that's a bad
thing there's nothing wrong with that
they have one thing in common
let's figure out a way to help advance
the economy and i'm going to be able to
help you create jobs let's do this
you don't have to agree with anything
that i do or any way i live
you don't even have to vote for me i'm
not even going to vote for you but i'll
sit there and do business with you
and i respect that salute to tim cook
well if you're listening to this
can you imagine he gets 500 tweets
saying i respect you tim cook
he's not even going to have a clue where
it's going to come from sometimes a guy
like that people forget to recognize him
for what he's doing
he's got to think it's because he
lowered the price on the app store
monopoly it is we always circle back to
that
anyways anyways so that's that's where
i'm at with that did you have final
thoughts on it or no
um two just two quick thoughts number
one you sort of reap what you sow the
nba has
come to this point where james harden is
this powerful because they've built this
entire league yeah on its players
whether it was magic and bird whether it
was jordan whether it was lebron
the players have the final say here and
then regarding social justice
i think it's just i just a little bit of
irony no major point here
that houston was the team that sort of
set this all off
with the dara mori's in support of hong
kong
uh tweet that he did a few years ago
circling back it's just ironic that now
houston is on the forefront of the
social justice anti-trump movement it's
just just a little ironic that you sort
of
that it's come to this we're going to
find out how powerful he is because i
don't think he's going to work his way
out of houston i don't i don't think
well he's got listen the reality is and
i don't want to go too deep on nba talk
because we know our audience isn't
exactly
nba he's got two years or three years
left on his contract they don't have to
do [ __ ] with him right now
you can say you're unhappy show your ass
up to work if you want your paycheck if
not
you're in breach of your comments by the
way by the way
if this thing becomes what it's becoming
i'm asking for a trade which anthony
davis did wanting to leave the pelicans
which is what harden's doing and this is
starting to become a movement
yeah um why the hell would i have a team
in a small market
so giannis comes out and says i want to
be traded next season because they
brought drew holiday and they don't want
a championship with middleton he wants a
trade now you're stuck with a middleton
and drew holiday neither one of them is
a
you know the difference between anthony
davis that he'd force his way out is
he had an uh an expiring contract yeah
they were going to lose him to free
agency
you've got two and a half years to even
worry about losing james harden so
my assumption is unless uh unless they
actually can get something back from
james harden i'm going to make a british
i'm going to make a prediction watch for
this happen in the next six months james
harden fires his agent
hires rich paul clutch sports run by
lebron he'll work his way out of houston
doing that back channeling it through
the most powerful force of the nba which
is lebron james and his agency clutch
sports
if he wants to do that he could do what
the hell he wants to do at the end of
the day these players can do what the
hell
they want to see that happening i can
see that happening i can see harden
talking to lebron right now saying hey
what do you think i should do i i see
that conversation taking place but
anyways it is what it is look
if you're watching this if you enjoyed
this last banter that we had the last
15-20 minutes hit that subscribe button
on the alert button if you enjoyed the
conversation we just had
the last 20 minutes over tim cook trump
and somehow the houston rockets
push that subscribe button much love to
those of you guys that did let's
continue okay
uh new york i got a video i want to
share to you guys yesterday
cuomo did you guys see that exchange
with cuomo yesterday cuomo had a big
exchange before you played i want to
read this to them but you can make it
get ready for it here's what happened
with new york new york schools shut down
indefinitely with new surge of cases let
me read that one more time to you
new york schools shut down indefinitely
with new surge of cases all students in
new york public schools will transition
to remote online learning beginning
thursday
today mayor de blasio announced
wednesday the kova 19 test positive rate
in the city
hit three percent over the past week
reaching the threshold that officials
said to determine
whether schools should be close closed
he said we must fight back the second
wave of covet 19 de blasio said
richard carranza the chancellor of new
york city department of education said
in a tweet that it was a temporary
closure
the mayor and i have been clear-eyed
since the beginning that we needed to
get students back into the classrooms as
soon as it was safe
and we carry the same urgency with us
today as we announced this temporary
closure we will get students back in
buildings as soon as we can safely
new york city public school system is
the largest in the nation serving more
than 1.1 million students according to
the new york city department of
education
and this is what happened yesterday kai
press play
this is the city's decision they have an
agreement at three percent
today you said well i might have to
impose an orange zone and i might have
to close the schools which an orange
zone does
so what's going on is the city still
have the ability to close at schools
are you now taking control and saying
that you have the power to make this
decision
and for the millions of parents who want
to know are the schools going to open
tomorrow in new york city
all right first of all let's try not to
be obnoxious
and offensive in your tone
because you're a hundred percent wrong
he sounds like trump there
we announced the orange that's the
ironic part law
over a month ago i don't know if you
were here
or if you were paying attention but that
has been really sounds like trump here
they're both from new york it always
said
if by the state's numbers you hit
3 percent the schools close
what's going on here is nothing that the
law hasn't said
for over a month we then
had to test out procedures if you were
paying attention
you would have known we closed the
schools in new york city two weeks ago
remember when we did an orange zone in a
red zone
in brooklyn and queens and we close
the schools don't you remember that
okay so don't you so what are you
talking about
how what are you talking about you're
now going to override
we did it already that's the law an
orange zone in a red zone follow the
facts
well then you're confused
are the schools going to be open
tomorrow the schools
are open by state law they're closed
right after that new york city he knew
that by the way new york city
yeah well i don't really care what you
no no go back a little bit go back
you got to hear the last seven seconds
just go back right there
that's the question i think jimmy's
correct in asking that question i don't
think it's obnoxious at all
well i don't really care what you think
here we go
sums them up right there you know what
he wants to do to that reporter he wants
to sock that guy
and deck him right in his shoulder yeah
that's what he's going to do
oh my god right in the shower so tell me
though i mean what do you think what's
going on in new york
the guy is clearly frustrated he's an
[ __ ] i mean i'm appalled by that
video he thinks he's al pacino you know
here's the problem with newsome and
cuomo
they think they're rock stars all right
they are so cocky they're so out of
control
they have so much power that they can
get away with crap like this
and what newsom's doing i can't stand
what they're doing i feel for the
parents in new york city who now have to
figure it out
once again what they're going to do with
their kids and let me just say this
kids have been robbed of a year of their
life it's been
stolen from them 60 of them at least
will never be able to make up what they
lost this past year
it is a crime what he is doing going up
there with the authority that he has
and to be that cocky and that out of
touch and that auto tune
and did you hear the other big story
about him yesterday he got a pay raise
he got a huge pay raise look it up kai
mario cuomo got a huge now he's going to
say he's going to turn it down right
yeah right it'll come back to him
sideways like nine different ways but
i'm appalled by that he thinks he's an
entertainer he thinks he's al pacino
leaning back like he's the godfather or
something it sickens me to see what
these guys are doing
they have no repercussions whatsoever so
point counterpoint here that
literally that's exactly what trump does
so if you don't like what if you don't
like quotes
the perception of people that hate trump
that thinks that's what he does that is
any difference between his death and his
interaction there's no
trump has respect i'm going to tell you
what you're
going to take off you listen to a trump
press conference he has respect for the
reporters
he answers their questions literally
living in different worlds there
there's no and i'm i'm i'm telling
someone who's
saying that his tone was wrong again one
of the things i'm able to do is
call [ __ ] on both sides the way that
he handled that reporter is exactly what
trump does
no if you don't see that then you're not
listening no the fact that you might
just be watching
america news or something like that that
doesn't show the reality of it
the reality is that's exactly how trump
treats reporters and if you don't
believe me i'm sure we could roll the
tape on every adaptation i'm just going
to be
unraveling of saying what you just said
is wrong that is not how trump
treats reporters he might hammer him in
a jury out of control
have you seen him interact he answers
questions they
badger the hell out of trump for four
years you're going to find out
where he got frustrated one or two times
but that is not
trump at all so trump is just a nice
chill guy that's the only defense that
people that hate trump have
is that you have to flip it and say oh
say the opposite of trump is what i'm
saying
the point that you're missing right now
you're failing to understand is this is
not an anti-trump thing
or a pro cuomo but the first direction
you took
relax i what i'm saying is they both
keyword both tom you understand what
that word means they both
treat reporters disrespectfully compared
to that but here's my point since i know
you have a
where'd you go to uh med school and all
where'd you go again here we go
the the guy can't get past their
emotions you have to sound smart
here we go where what what what do you
think you should do keep everything open
just not
pay zero attention to covid i'm asking
you not to not to complain
not to criticize to give a solution it's
not my job to give a solution
what's your job to criticize what i can
tell you damn right
my point is i like to listen to to
scientists
okay and if they're basically saying hey
you know where else they're shutting
down
freaking kansas freaking north dakota
minnesota this isn't just a new york
thing
or a california these leftist liberals
they're shutting everything down they're
robbing the kids of school
coveted cases have increased they've
been there's our second wave coming i
know that record on quote
rounding the curve i don't have it's
cold weather's cold
cool second wave is coming it's coming
colds are coming
up go make your point though i'm curious
my point is let's it's so easy to
criticize the
the and i'm being critical of his tone
as well here i'm not
vouching like i'm not vouching for cuomo
yeah but it is clearly his frustration
was they've had guidelines in place
if cases have gone from orange to red or
whatever the protocol is
he's basically getting frustrated with
the reporter saying yo bro like
this has been in place four weeks two
weeks the reporter said no three weeks
and he's like well that's exactly what i
just said what are you talking about
here he's getting frustrated cool i'm
cool with that
but there's protocol in place and if you
reach a certain point and the medical
authorities are like
hold on freaking kovid's out of control
he's
listening to the medical authorities
here so that's my point so overall
his tone was a [ __ ] [ __ ] just like
trump
is a [ __ ] [ __ ] to reporters so i'm
calling it on both sides
yeah but to say that only cuomo is the
[ __ ] here and trump has never
disrespected a reporter
is outlandish has trump not taking
ridiculous tones
he's called media the enemy of the state
he's argued with reporters non-stop
forget about his reaction what i'm
asking you now yes what do you think
about what new york is doing
what do you think about shutting down
schools indefinitely what do you think
about that
they're doing the right thing with three
percent that now is kovitz shown three
percent
let's shut down the whole school is that
the right thing to do i don't think that
that school should be shut down
indefinitely
like never definitely let me think let
me let me take it a different angle and
i'll
i'll address everything you guys just
said number one their their style cuomo
the way he speaks versus the way
trump speaks um i think trump
is a little less the word i'm looking
for
he's a little less condescending in
interviews i think trump is a counter
puncher himself his entire life he's
been a counter puncher
but if you come and do you do a good
interview with him he's very respectful
he'll go through the whole thing with
you
and he gets hit up a million times more
than cuomo does cuomo doesn't get hit up
okay
when cuomo gets hit up you just saw the
way he reacted trump gets hit up
every single flipping day
every second he's getting get up not
como cuomo was a hero
during coronavirus the pandemic and he
was he had the worst
city and worst state out of everybody he
had those that's where he started out of
everybody
and he is a hero they're treating him
like a hero like this is a guy
democrats 2024 you know somebody that
could potentially be a future president
he'd be maybe a few months ago no no are
you going on record saying that trump
does not have contentious arguments
let me make the media let me make my
second part of the point what do christy
trump and kumal have in common they're
all from new york they're all from
jersey new york man that's how they talk
that's how they are i do business with
people from new york because they tell
me how it is i
i don't mind doing business with them
but america doesn't
know new york mike pence doesn't talk
like that thank you so much kristen for
that question kamala congratulations on
being the first
right so let me address the issue when
it comes trump would never answer
something like that neither would him
right both tough guys from now they're
from new york
i have no problem with that i'm very
comfortable with that now let's talk
about the school and stuff shutting down
let's talk about that okay
so how many teenagers do you hear dying
from coronavirus
how many people oh no actually how many
two there was two in california
is it probably six thousand how many
teenagers have we heard dying from uh
flu now how many people have we heard
dying from uh
obesity that ends up leading to heart
attack and diabetes how many
how many people die from heart attack
how many people die from their body not
moving
how come we're not talking like you for
instance yesterday and i were talking
you were exercising
and you're going to the gym how many
times you're working out right now how
many times you're working out right now
kai
how many times you're working out right
now how many times you're working out a
week what do you do five days a week are
you a four day
eric are you five there right now i'm
trying to catch up with homework but
usually four days ago
how many times you work out you're how
are you by the way you're how old 39 and
a half okay
how many times a week you're working out
three four days a week why do you work
out three four days a week to stay
healthy
what does that mean what does that mean
tell me what that means in what respect
in what respect what does it mean to
stay healthy
eat well exercise why does exercise why
exercise
where are you going with this point what
i'm asking you is why exercise what's
the big deal about exercising
what's the big deal about moving your
body what's the big deal about
doing anything with moving your body why
do we move our body if we don't move our
body what happens
it gets weaker if we get and then what
happens if we get fat and sloppy what
happens to our immune system you get a
higher risk for covid
you get a high risk for sickness period
not covet your immune system gets
weaker this has got to be the dumbest
stupidest thing that people are doing
not realizing that if your body doesn't
flip and move
you get sick shutting down gyms is
ruining your health
people got to exercise the more you
exercise they're healthier yeah what
does this have to do with kids
everything kids go to school they move
their bodies they get in shape they do
all this other stuff they're feeling
better
this is good for them what the kids are
doing they got to be out there now you
want to shut them down for what so your
point just to be clear is
they should not shut down any schools
ever zero at all
zero at all now teachers who are above
60 years old
let them go home teachers who are 60
years old and up let them go home
now i'm not talking about teachers being
over 60 years old teachers who have
issues with asthma with certain issues
like that that's been documented not
all of a sudden have asthma today you
know what i'm talking about that you
have documentation
hey let's let's address them in a
different way what do you mean sending
to
question questions yeah because i want
to get i want to you know school
i'm just going to go you know rapid fire
you give me your thoughts real quick
schools 100 stay open no matter what is
that what you're saying kids needs
kids need to be out there yes we're not
talking enough about the concerts what
about these guys what about
gyms gyms need to be open all gyms gyms
need to be 100 open
bars i don't care about bars so bars do
what
what do bars do though bars you hang out
and you talk and you drink
fine i the bars i'm indifferent about
stay open fifty percent fifty percent is
fine so fifty percent
restaurants yeah uh restaurants seventy
five percent fifty to seventy five i'm
borrowing restaurant to me is 50 to 75
percent
uh sports arenas football fields
basketball courts the whole 50
okay so they're you do have restrictions
on certain things fine
for now you're saying a hundred percent
hundred percent certain thing
for sure not be open nothing nothing
nothing okay zero nothing should close
this is a little bit worse than a flu
a little bit worse than a flu pad you
want to do the math yeah let's do that
pull up
as far as how many people have ten times
a amount of people have died this year
versus the flu what age though
i'm not talking about it okay listen to
school i just want you to yeah that's
incorrect that's an actual inaccurate
statement 40 000 people die of the year
of the flu 250 000 people have died no
of corona
way more people die from the flu than
forty thousand hold this [ __ ] up right
now guys
but buddy keep going with your point
here here's my question for you
um is it there's no point this is a
question here yeah so
is it the kids that if they do get
covered well cool cool they'll be fine
but they give it to their parent or they
give it to their grandparent or their
aunt uncle that they live with
and then there's the ramifications of
that like
your your dad comes and visits you once
a month yep your kids go to school
they're fine no worries about daily
you know about tico no worries god
forbid god forbid they pass that along
to
an elder person that comes along god
forbid they give that to your father
that's the concern that's a that's a
that's not a point that's a question
is there a concern of that that a kid
gets sick he gets the covet whatever
whatever whatever
and they pass it along to an elder
person in the family let me let me give
you a completely different a different
point of it as well
what's the alternative for my 78 year
old dad
home by himself for the next two years
the hell kind of a life is that you
don't think a 78 year old is sitting
there thinking how many more years do i
have left
you don't think a 78 year old sitting
there saying which would i rather have
spend time with my grandkids
or sit in home by myself looking at
these damn pictures
what do you think of 70 selfish you say
i'm 78 years old
say you were 78 years old you got five
grandkids
you got four grandkids what are you
gonna do for thanksgiving i want to say
you you're 78 you got five grandkids
thanksgiving is coming up do you want to
go to thanksgiving even with the risk of
potentially getting coronavirus what do
you want to do at 78.
i'm gonna tell you what i'm gonna do i'm
curious what you're gonna do at 78. if
you're 78 and you've got i mean look at
you
i'm asking you okay you're 78 it's 30 38
years from now 39 years from now you
have five grandkids that's thanksgiving
christmas
you want to skip christmas every
thanksgiving with them my entire life
yeah and you're saying hey man for this
one thanksgiving
you should consider maybe not traveling
you wouldn't want to see your grandkids
that's not the emotional asking you yes
don't tell me logic you
what do you want to do if i'm freaking
78 years old what do you want to do and
i have
health issues that's the key thing have
health issues my dad's had 13 heart
attacks okay i'd be
concerned about traveling and spending
would you rather
would you would you rather be on shut
down for the next six 12 18 months
and be in a room by yourself risk
that loneliness at 78 years old and your
brain is going a million miles an hour
overthinking everything
or would you rather say i'm going to
tell my kids
please be responsible please do certain
things when i come in i don't want to
hug my dad and i would talk when you're
coming we don't hug
so you're saying listen show up but
don't come give me don't hug
he says when you come in okay so this is
my point no it's not your point
i'm asking you a question that you're
not answering okay so here we go but
we're getting i'm saying you're saying
that we're getting somewhere
to show up i'm bringing it to you i ask
you forget about what i'm saying
but you just said something that's
important but i'm just telling your kids
i'm asking you
i'm asking for your advice you're 78
yeah
you got five grandkids yes you don't see
them every day because they live
somewhere else because the parents
decided to go somewhere else because
your daughter married a guy
who has a career in jersey who's working
out of dc was working out of alabama he
got a job there
they want to come see you you want to go
see them you're not going to go see your
grandkids
allow me to answer yes please obviously
if i'm 70 freaking 8 years old
50 years from now i would love to see my
grandkids yeah
no question okay what's more concerned
for you
is it more the concern of getting
chronic virus or the concern of
you may never see your kids again
because you're seven years old the
answer is it can be both
the answer is it can be both i want to
see my grandkids clearly right i mean
who doesn't want to see their
grandchildren
but at the same time there is something
called the freaking pandemic going on
sure
so as you just said yeah maybe your kids
don't give grandma
uh uh grandpa kiss you said yourself
that maybe dylan doesn't get to sleep in
the same bed as his grandfather
maybe like what rules have you put in
place he shows up
does he wear a mask does he not wear i'm
asking you no listen let me give
let me give one thing that coronavirus
has done that i give
the the positive of chronovirus what is
that everyone's on the junction
here's what coronavirus has done what
chronovirus has done is the following
chronovirus has gotten me to pay
more attention to cleanliness
coronavirus has gotten me to
pay closer attention to when the kids
are sick to not go lay down with papa
coronavirus has gotten me to be a little
bit more careful with my dad when
chronovirus first initially came guess
what
i call my dad i said dad and i told him
i said that you're not leaving the house
so what are you talking about i said you
didn't live in a house
so i'm going to leave the house and go i
said dad you're not leaving the house
i said this to my dad you're not in
march april march 11th march 12th i said
you're not leaving a house he says i'm
leaving the house my you don't tell my
dad what to do my dad's a
very strong personality by the way for
the record i love your guys i know
you're doing it he loves you he's your
number one fan all right so and
and here we go and he says i'm not
leaving the house i said okay
i said i said you're not leaving the
house you know what happened i kept
checking on him every day
no i'm here do you know two months later
he lied to me do you know he started
working but he didn't want to tell me
really he didn't want to tell me so i
caught him
and i called him we got into it you know
what he finally said to me
what the hell you want me to do stay
home yeah what do you want me to do
you want me to stay home i have nothing
to do i have to do something
i totally hear you on that i'm not
saying that he should be sheltered in
place he taught
me i don't know what it is to be 78
years old
you don't know what it is to be 78 years
old i only
know what it is to be a 42 year old man
in my situation
and i want to hear from a 78 year old he
says i can't stay home
if i stay home i get sick i have to go
out and do things you get sick like
emotionally mentally sick because you're
not creating anybody the most bitter
people in the world are those that don't
create
the most bitter people are the ones that
are sitting there doing nothing if you
ever find that make a list of the most
bitter people in your life
and right then what did they create
lately nothing if you don't create
anything you get bitter
people need to create things to be happy
says i need to go out and build
something
that's my dad 78 years old so here's my
question because we'll i'm sure we're
gonna have to move on a sec
what is your dad doing for thanksgiving
and what
he's going to be in dallas and what
rules are you going to put in he has a
room for himself
okay and he has a room for himself and
he hangs out with the kids
while he's there when i come in i don't
kiss him on the cheek we always kiss on
the cheek
and it's more fist bump and hey what's
up you know we go in he tells us what he
wants to do
why are you doing a kiss on the cheek
and why are you doing fist bumps because
he's comfortable with it he says you
know what it's
let's uh cover it by the way he coughed
in a yukon so both
yeah you know let me say this three
points i'm going to make real quickly
number one
the shutdowns are not about covid okay
period end of discussion
number two there's a certain percentage
of people in this country that want to
save everybody
that everything has to be safe that
there's no risk at all and and a lot of
them are governors
and the third thing is the shutdowns we
did in the spring didn't work
these aren't going to work either let's
just crush some more businesses
let's just take more restaurants out and
their ability to support their family
and even live
let's just let's make gym owners bear
the brunt of this how about you own a
spa
or you own a nail salon oh you're not
allowed to be in this country anymore
and thrive and do anything it's all a
joke and it goes back to
mr cuomo and his attitude they want to
control everything about everybody's
lives
for the sake of saving everyone and
that's the bottom line so
your your point is everything should be
100 open everything
i'm not answering these questions what
are you talking about you don't ask
rational questions i'm asking you a
question
tom rational question but you're not
everything be a hundred percent
i'm not arguing for something ask me any
question i'll answer it you're like duck
all these questions the question i'm
asking you is very point blank dude
should everything be 100 open
i'm not a governor i don't make these
decisions it's not up to me
i should be shut down at least i don't
set policy
i don't look at percentages of what
needs to be shut down
i give you a broad picture perspective
of reality
of what's going on in this world for
non-naive people
i'm looking right now no i'm looking
right at you i respect what you're
saying i really do
but i'm asking you generally right here
looking at you what should not be a
hundred percent right now
again this is this is veering the
podcast into a direction it doesn't need
to go
that's not my way to talk about
everything
you just said you give your opinion so
i'm not looking for scientific facts
yeah but you just asked me for a fact
you asked me i'm asking you
in your opinion what percentage of
things should not be a hundred percent
i want to comment on the issues that
we're talking about we were talking
about new york city the country's losing
its mind
there's mystery so so everything so by
based on what you said
everything should be 100 open again this
these are not questions i'm going to
answer because what do you mean you go
again
because you're trying to back me into a
corner that i'm not even near
i'm not even near a clown tom tom tom
this is us talking here buddy
forget we're on a podcast forget it
forget about the audience next subject
the audience loves you i'm asking you
what should be
again not a hundred percent this this is
not listen i'm gonna help you out here
you can even just use his notes pat said
bars should be 50 restaurants 75
that's fine pat gave an answer he didn't
duck out of it
do you can just say i agree with pat i
agree those should be the numbers you
can get out of this and just i agree
with that
by the way good mother just said the
shutdowns are exposing the people
in the wrong seats love it government
should not be moms
uh meaning shouldn't be moms like hey
i'm going to take care of you and
protect you but let's transition from
this topic here's my point bottom line
is
yeah we're here at work every single day
yep have i ever
called in that i'm in my basement today
pat you have not have i showed up every
single freaking day don't worry
do i not leave here until 10 pm every
single night sometimes midnight okay
yeah those are crazy
i will say this church should be 50 okay
there we go tom just answered the
question ladies and gentlemen
so if churches should be 50 percent
is that what you just said churches need
to be open they're not open in college
churches should there we go so there's
some rules and regulations in place i
like it tom
i'm proud of you by the way i think you
guys need to go have a drink together
tom doesn't drink i would love to drink
i'd like to get wasted but tom has never
had a drink the one day in the podcast
tom what are you drinking what are you
talking are you drinking i i haven't had
a drink on the podcast
what are you drinking i like tequila and
i like bourbon yeah we had we had a
one time we went to uh chamberlain's and
we got that uh the old fashioned we had
some old-fashioned was phenomenal yeah
he'll have an old-fashioned and maybe
you guys can hash it out
there's nothing nice i'm asking tom a
question and he's saying that he doesn't
want to answer it but he did
he did answer this these aren't these
aren't trick questions so you think i'm
trying to trick you but by the way
you just answered the same question i
asked let's go on a softer topic before
we go on a stronger topic here
once you pull out what happened so i
decided to put two of my cars
at an auction okay i have two of my uh
cars i was approached by heritage
auctions and they put my two cards on
heritage
this is one of them the wayne gretzky 10
his rookie card 1979
the minimum reserve if you want to bid
for this right now it's 575
000 it would end up costing you 690
that's the next bid there's still
21 days left on this the minimum reserve
on this if you go lower to buy
this card go lower lower lower lower
it's a million dollars the reserve is at
a million dollars and people want that
card there's only two of them in the car
that's the holy grail
of the hockey card world i have no clue
what it's going to sell for
but uh we will know by december 14. the
next one is a tops card there's only two
of these
the next bid right the current bid is to
uh 210 the next bit is 220
with the 20 feet that heritage offer
charges you would be 264.
the two cards holy grail of hockey cards
on the market
you set the price because they're yours
they call me they came and approached me
a lot of guys wanted this had a call
with uh bruce mcnally's ball wayne
gretzky you know the guy they want
honest wagner together him and he was a
former owner the
kings himself and uh i started getting a
lot of weird calls and i bought this
couple years ago i sent tikrun to go
pick it up and they went to psa
headquarters
and they got the card uh uh in a brand
new case and
the guy needed cash and i said no
problem wired them uh of
some money and we got the cards and i
didn't know what is going to happen with
it i was going to hang on to it
but then heritage came up to us the
owners they came we had a meeting here
they said let us
take the card and see what we can do
with it we'll offer a minimum at a
million
and 400 000 and you know we'll see
what's going to happen with this at this
point
um people are starting to realize how
much money there are
in collectibles you know a a matt
a mike trout card just sold for what 3.9
million dollars uh i spoke to the three
owners who owned the mickey mantle if
you go to 1952 tops
uh type in 1952 tops in search go to
google and type it make it don't don't
leave this side
yeah 1952 tops mickey mantle
ps there you go psa 10 go down there's
only three of them in the world
one of them doesn't want to sell the
other one is open to it and the third
one is asking me for 18 million dollars
to buy this card
uh click on images and we are actually
talking right now to see if that's
something i'm willing to do and i'm
definitely not going to go to 18 million
but uh
psa 10 right click on the first one
right here right there no no right here
right below it right below forbes right
there click on that
that's the card that is a that was uh
sold
two years ago for 12 million dollars um
that's an older price that they have on
there but it sold two years ago espn
reported 12 million dollars
that is today probably a anywhere
between 12 to 18 million auto card
1952 is that a real autograph or is that
just no that's not
that's that's the card that's like the
holy grail of cards
the mickey mantle that's the number this
is this has done laps over a hundred
swagger because
wagner they found that that it was cut
with scissors
on why the quality was so good they said
the perfect one was cut with scissors so
that's right now probably still worth 4
million what's that worth
that's probably a 15 million dollar card
you're looking at so you just buy that
with
you buy this card with for 15 million
bucks and you hang on to it for 20 years
you'll probably sell it for 50 million
bucks in 20 years
so you'll make 35 million in 20 years
you may make that money better in other
places but it's
like if you appreciate cards holding on
to that card is like
man it's like katherine zitter jones in
that movie going and stealing the most
expensive diamond in the world do you
remember that one movie what was the
movie with sean connery
she's going through the whole thing and
showing her body with the red the hell
was that movie i don't know what was it
called that movie
that's what this is yeah this is the
holy grail so heritage asked me if you
want to go back to it if you have any
interest you can go to heritage auctions
type in wayne gretzky and if you want to
make an offer to add this to your
collectible this is probably going to be
a 10 15 20 million dollar card
in the next 10 or 20 years so that's
what we have there with that now
for some of you guys that are traveling
your business folks and you're going out
to use your phones a lot your iphone
the other day again i went to um yard
house the other day
and i was at yard house and i typically
use yard house wi-fi for my ipad
and i went to use it and boom i had my
expressvpn on and they said oh you got
to be careful with this you got to be
careful with this but then i was
protected right
and and a lot of times nowadays folks
you have to realize this again if you're
in business and you have
private information a lot of people save
their passwords here and it's the
easiest way to get your password
here's what we decided to do we rarely
bring in people that we have as sponsors
we're very selective adam's been working
very closely
with the folks expressvpn uh is one that
we feel very confidently working with
here's why
doesn't matter if you get your internet
from verizon comcast
anybody else isps in the us can legally
sell your information
uh to ad campaigns expressvpn is an app
that reroutes your internet connection
through their secure
servers so the isp cannot see the sites
you visit
expressvpn also keeps all of your
information secure by
encrypting a hundred percent of your
data with the most powerful encryption
available most of the time i don't even
realize
i have it on because you just press on
the green thing comes up
and it runs seamlessly in the background
and it's easy to use and by the way it
doesn't slow down your phone your ipad
anything and expressvpn is available on
all devices phones computers and even
smart tv so there's no excuse for you to
use it
uh protect your online activity today
with the vpn rated number one by cnet
and wired visit my
exclusive link expressvpn.com one more
time expressvpn.com forward slash
pbd vpn expressvpn
dot com forward slash pbd vpn you'll get
a three month free membership with a 12
month
subscription highly highly recommend
you go out there and do this with
expressvpn if you haven't already done
so click on the link below in our
description kai put that
link in the comment section so people
can go to it as well uh thank you again
to expressvpn so
hockey card a million bucks wayne
gretzky
what do you think that's gonna go for
it's right now six hundred thousand
dollars 580 it's gonna
it's got 21 more days left what do you
think it's going to go for some are
saying it's going to go
into in a two and a half three million
some are saying it's going to go one to
one and a half million what do you think
that's going to go for
the question is what do you think it's
going to go i have no idea it's going to
go for north of 3 million because
someone's going to be bored
and they're going to drunk bid on that
thing and it's going to go away
i tell you what happened remember the
kobe kobe bryant ford thing that was
selling that was autographed if you want
to go back on that picture only 600 000
was it that was 6 30 but they said it
was only gonna sell for like four five
hundred thousand dollars
and i was sitting there bidding it was
three of us middle of the night were
bidding for it and the next thing you
know
you know i was willing to go up to seven
six hundred thousand dollars but i
wasn't willing to go to 700
and it sold for i think 650 600 some
thousand dollars i was very annoyed when
i lost that one yeah 631
is what it sold for so it's going to be
interesting the mike
truck click on my trout rookie card 3.9
million kai go to google type in mike
trout
mike trout rookie card 3.9 million
card uh kai is killing it with the
spelling decision there you go 3.9
million right there just click down
below okay
uh go to all go to all yeah
right there click on that this just so
three months ago by the way
for 3.9 million dollars see if they got
the picture there or not go back up
okay go back you'll see the picture
click on yeah right there rob report
go down a little bit that's the picture
that card sold for 3.9 million dollars
look at young elix that card so for 3.9
million
and by the way back in 2018 it sold for
four hundred thousand dollars
so went from four hundred thousand
dollars nothing changed the same card in
two years sold for 3.9 million dollars
right now the right cards are very good
investments they're great if you get the
right cards
i don't recommend buying anything that's
just a a regular card
i recommend buying holy grail i prefer
older cards more than i do new cards
because new cards sometimes it can be a
lot of reprints
but older cards if you can get them and
put them away and if you have the money
for it it's going to make you
money no matter what long term i don't
know anything about the card game but
whoever had that first did they
literally open it up in a package that
they got at fry's grocery store it's
like a winning lottery ticket
and then this thing gets circulated
that's it i mean it was for sale with a
pack of bubble gum too right
i mean that's unbelievable old school
with the bubble gum and so what
how what's why is this valued so much
because they only had so many at the
time
interesting that the key word with this
you said you it's at heritage auction
heritage auction okay so you know you
know what happens the second word
auction what you're hoping for is it's
you know you're gonna get bid you're
gonna get bid you're gonna get and then
you're just gonna have two or three
people
just still battling it out at the end
and they just it becomes a pissing
here's what you have to do the other guy
that owned there's only two of those
cards in the world one is me one is the
other guy it's two of us
we both know each other the other guy
has no desire to sell it
zero he's not gonna ever sell it the
other guy is me
okay for me i'm not a hockey guy
i'm a investment guy and wayne gretzky
is the goat there's no one even comes
close to what this guy did with his
career
a card like this you're not if you ever
get a guy that's on a card like this and
it's a good price even if you pay a
couple million for it you're going to be
able to hang on to it for a while
and be patient you're going to make your
money back because cars like this don't
come around all the time
so there's going to be a few people that
are going to want this car we'll find
out who it's going to be we'll announce
it matter of fact when the auction ends
i think in december 14 whatever the date
is we'll announce what it sold for i
have no idea what it's going to go for
but we'll see
okay let's talk about amazon amazon just
put the entire health care industry on
notice with its latest push into
pharmacy here's
who stands to win or lose through amazon
pharmacy customers can shop for drugs
and get them shipped in a mail prime
members can also receive discounts on
the medication
it's part of amazon's slow but steady
entry into the u.s healthcare system
some healthcare companies
like drug wholesalers stand to benefit
as amazon pushes deeper into healthcare
while businesses like retail pharmacies
stand to lose out as
more prescriptions go online cvs
walgreens especially smaller right a
took hits
to their stocks on tuesday while the
prime savings could very well drive some
incredible volume to their shops recall
that the prime discounts
work in the brick and mortar pharmacies
too the service
puts amazon in direct competition with
pharmacies that's online business has
already been heard what are your
thoughts well you know now i know why
bezos
hated trump so much because it really
makes sense to have people at home where
they have to buy everything without
leaving the house
it's unbelievable i mean this is
brilliant um cvs's stock fell
8.5 as soon as this was announced
walgreens went down 10.3
and good rx went down 15 percent it's a
4 trillion
dollar industry wow 4 trillion the thing
um are old people going to feel
comfortable i mean what's the percentage
of old people that buy
pharmaceuticals it's probably pretty
high they let this every time i go to
cvs or walgreens it seems like they like
to be in there
and and touching it and feeling it and
talking to their pharmacist
it's just going to be another example of
what amazon wants amazon gets and even
if they get a
what a third of that pie that's a lot of
money i mean of a four trillion dollar
industry
it's it's unbelievable how strategic
amazon is and how they get what they
want and how successful they are
perfect segue to my point they are
strategic they are
aggressive and they are relentless
matter of fact kai pulled this up
if you go to relentless.com go to
relentless.com
what comes up oh my god it's amazon
go to relentless.com amazon shows up so
just to put it in mind to put it in
perspective
of how aggressive and relentless
amazon is no matter what sector there
you go there's some proof you go to
relentless.com amazon is there
they ain't stopping so if you had any
questions of how big amazon wants to get
they are the gorilla in the room and
they want to be the biggest baddest mofo
gorilla
in the history of any room what are they
going to get into next is a question i
mean they're just looking at whatever's
the biggest industry they want to get
into it
and and they're doing a similar thing
with apple as well because
amazon is what apple is apple is the
phone you use but amazon is the store
you go to and by the way remember this
no one buys stuff on amazon on iphone
let me say that one more time you don't
buy stuff on amazon's
app because amazon doesn't sell anything
on their app
you know why they don't sell anything on
their app because they don't want to pay
the 30 to apple
everything you ever buy from amazon it's
from their
online amazon.com not from their app you
cannot buy a single product on amazon's
app
not one product did anybody know did you
know explain that to me because if i go
on my app what is it
you cannot buy and it'll take you
straight to amazon.com you cannot buy
a product on amazon
what a brilliant thing he's got you
cannot buy amazon books
when you want to buy an amazon book you
have to go buy amazon book on amazon.com
audible and then it shows up on the
amazon app so they've figured out a way
to avoid having to pay that 30 percent
yeah you got to give them credit they're
geniuses they are relentless they are
relentless how much is bezos driving the
ship as far as the strategy and the
planning is he still the guy
i i think he is the guy but at that
point have you guys read the book no
rules rules at netflix have you read
that book
it is a ridiculous book ridiculous book
that is so
unconventional and i bet it's the kind
of a book a boss doesn't want to give to
their employees the ceo of netflix wrote
that
yes he wrote it with a critic he wrote
it with a critic
that he said i want to bring current and
they went and interviewed former
employees who hated netflix
and love netflix and they tell it all
every story good bad ugly they tell it
and one thing one thing you notice when
when reed hastings talks about how he
manages his team
is it's at a point right now where you
simply pick a great team
and they go out and get the job done and
you kind of are monitoring it and some
of the bigger decisions run
through you one of his main guys that
was going and picking up the shows he is
now the co-ceo ted surrender is now the
co-ceo they just announced them i think
july
or something like they became the co-ceo
netflix so you know
companies that size amazon listen you're
doing a trillion two trillion dollars a
year
when you're doing a couple trillion when
you do any kind of business that they're
two trillion dollar company
when you're doing as much business as
they're doing you're pretty much a small
country
yeah your country you're no longer a
business you are a country which means
you have governors you have
senators you have businessmen you have a
lot of different people that help run
the decisions but the big one always
comes through you so what was the news
uh speaking of how big and bad they want
to get there was ru
news a few weeks ago that they're
considering looking into buying cnn
something like that yes
it's a brilliant move by the way
somebody asked me would you buy cnn i
said in a heartbeat i would buy cnn
uh uh uh see if you can get your hands
on cnn
you're it's a brilliant move look what
happened to fox look what happened to
fox fox is no longer fall
right wing fox is no longer right wing
fox is in the middle today
fox's uh fox was the first that came out
with arizona before anybody else
yeah you know fox news came out and said
you know biden won arizona
and trump and all the people were pissed
off saying why are you reporting
fox is no longer what people thought fox
was pre
you know 2018 2017 viewers going over to
other stations i know you're a big cnn
but do you um no you're you're right i
mean their viewership has gone down
drastically and i think that's a that's
a like a litmus test for
you know politically when you get too
involved and you are not flexible
whatsoever in business in politics in
media
there will be repercussions down the
line and fox is seeing it right now
yes they are they're definitely seeing
it okay next topic bitcoin approaching
its all-time high values over the past
few days
have fluctuated between 16 000 560 and
464. it's not uncommon
for wide fluctuations to occur with the
value of bitcoin having gained nearly 70
percent this quarter
at the time of publication one bitcoin
is worth 17418.
the all-time high meanwhile was recorded
december 17 2017.
as of the morning of wednesday november
18 prices on the digital currency went
to 18 000
just a few hundred dollars short of the
all-time high which is 19
783 if you own
bitcoin let us know you own bitcoin and
if you own bitcoin you're probably
excited right now so why do you think
bitcoin is getting close to its all-time
high so do you own any bitcoin
i used to own bitcoin you sold i sold do
you own anything i don't know
i i don't even know anything about it to
be honest i own some bitcoin okay
um back in i don't know 2017 i
i threw down 25 gs on bitcoin just you
know
buy and hold strategy so now you know
when it plummeted over the last few
years like i wasn't gonna sell i didn't
need the cash i'm good
so i just sat and let it see how it
played out
and i you know i'm happy i did we'll see
where it goes
now there's some people that say that
bitcoin is going to go down to zero and
crash
and there's some people that think it's
gonna go up to a hundred thousand
dollars but you know what what you do
know in investing if you believe in the
asset class
you buy and you hold long term where's
your 25 000 at now
uh in the 40-something range okay
okay all right cool yeah so three years
you kept it it went all the way down
probably to eight thousand dollars but
yeah yeah
yeah yeah so uh good for you for having
the patience of buying home but that's
the whole point with investing if you're
trying to get in and get out and get
rich quick like that's
you shouldn't be an investor be a j
trader just go to vegas and gamble but
if you believe in the asset class i
don't necessarily believe in
bitcoin or any of these little bit other
things i do believe that cryptocurrency
and blockchain is a real thing i don't
think that it's
nonsense or bs there are some legitimate
stuff and as we've seen
with our good friend robert kiyosaki who
came on recently
as they're printing more money and
hyperinflation
and uh just printing money left and
right what's the term that i'm
the quantitative quantitative easing
there we go um and if there's so much
money that they're putting out there
then you put your money into little safe
harbors he said he's a big fan of silver
and gold and bitcoin so interesting
perspective so so
think about it this way when when
products such as bitcoin
gold you know do well precious metals do
well what does it tell you
people why people are afraid people are
afraid when products like bitcoin
and gold do well people are afraid when
products like gold
and precious metals do well that means
we are printing way too much money
if biden becomes president and is no
longer president like he becomes
president
gold is going to go up because they're
going to keep printing money with
stimulus over and over and over again i
don't think they're going to get away
with the covet stuff anytime soon
the moment they stop printing money and
the economy is back open and people are
working you're going to see the price of
bitcoin and you're going to see the
price of gold go down
the moment that takes place right now
people are afraid
and bitcoin is a is a method of
protecting yourself
against anything that's going to happen
with the manipulation i mean i've had
some of these guys on a bitcoin world on
and uh i don't see it slowing down
anytime soon
i don't see bitcoin slowing down anytime
soon um question
you talking if you could time bitcoin if
you could time bitcoin
on the moment things open back up
bitcoin will go down
that's when you would sell it would so a
question for you now we've seen moderna
and we've seen pfizer 90
94.5 95 whether that's a cat and mouse
game or actually i just hope that it's
real
you talked about another stimulus point
i think there will be another stimulus
plan that's gold
stimulus is going to help gold precious
metals and gold is going to do all the
more money
but you said that there might be more
more stimulus but the more they print
the more gold so
in my opinion there'd be one more
stimulus and then hopefully there's
places like new york and california
react the way they do to covet and keep
schools shut down we're gonna need more
than one stimulus so let's just say
there's two stimulus let's say
biden's gonna do two of them one in uh
january and let's just say he does one
in
july okay one injury if it passes let's
pass yeah no but he can still do an 800
million dollar one 800 billion is still
plenty of money by the way if you print
800 billion
these days 800 billion is nothing unless
you're talking trillion dollars
a high roller like you put 25 000 in
bitcoin man 800 billion is a lot of
money
yeah i've clearly joking here but one
thing to my friends out there who are
we have i think we would it would be
fair to say we have a lot of bitcoin
enthusiasts that probably follow our
channel would you say yes okay here's my
advice
to my friends out there i put five
percent
of my asset into bitcoin five percent
there's so many people i talk to when i
say oh you have bitcoin
hell yeah i got bitcoin oh you have
anything in the stock market no way
do you have anything uh s p index fund
oh no i don't have anything with that
yeah you have any bonds no
nothing they're just 100 bitcoin that is
a recipe
for disaster so just quote me on that so
if you have some bitcoin cool respect
do not let that be your only investment
you could be in
very murky waters uh long term if that's
all you have mercury waters what are
what are the twins from facebook
are those still the the the winklebus
yeah they were big they they uh what
were they ethereum was that their thing
i'm sure our our audience uh let us your
thoughts know
bitcoin nate watering just gave five
dollars a bitcoin isn't just money
bitcoin is entire financial industry and
technology
good mother back at it again kamala
doesn't belong in any of the seats she
needs to
go adopt some children and uh possibly
get some cash
he's probably a big fan good old
currency hex the
x return this year alone cryptocurrency
hex did somebody give five bucks there
see what the name was so i can give a
shout out to manuel so we'll see what's
gonna happen with cryptocurrency do you
want to talk about moderna next
no here's what i'd like to talk about if
you don't mind um today's thursday
what's one week from now
thanksgiving yeah that's thanksgiving is
your dad coming to town
yeah he is that's a big thing are you
what are you doing for thanksgiving
we're gonna have a bunch of people over
we are yeah okay well when i say we are
you are well matter of fact we're gonna
have
probably 50 people over okay and
we're going to social distance six feet
from each other at the house
and some are gonna sit in the backyard
some in the garage some second floor
some outside of the house
well you know where i'll be i'll be in
your basement and you don't even have a
basement
you know where i'll be buddy but what
are you doing
this song i would love to know of course
leading the songs we
uh what did we fall down is it we fall
down we fall down
no i thought i thought you're gonna say
uh we cry
holy holy i thought you're gonna go with
jolene
jolene that's dolly parton that's
definitely a call back
what else are we doing here on
valuetainment though on black friday
that's something that i think we should
maybe bring up oh you know what yeah we
are doing black
friday very excited very excited adam
spearheading this adam came and changed
the game with the story we have why
don't you tell us about something oh
this is i want you
i mean we got you you got adidas stuff
you got nike we've got some new
techniques we're launching the new
vitamix
sick we got some sick stuff let's hear
about what we got going on let's talk
about some of these
yeah it's going to be big sales like 50
off 50 percent off sale it's gonna be
pretty sick i mean we're pretty much not
making money the whole purpose is
go sport the value and gear in some new
stuff that you got it's not about us
making money we want guys to wear it and
it's gonna be some real
cool gear adam what side do they need to
go on to stay updated with the black
friday deal that's coming out
how do people get connected that's a
good question
we can get the link so people know what
meanwhile let's go to the next topic
with moderna while you find that link
we'll put it below because i know some
people want to know
oh you put it already in the description
where is it in there
forward slash yeah if you can go to that
you'll see shout it out there some of
the stuff will come but you're also
going to be i think be calling people
who buy
yes you're going to be facetiming
something we got a whole plan going
we've got a whole people
sorry that we're slowly rolling those
people you're placing some orders
facetiming them yep showing off some of
the stuff yeah
we've gotta share the pictures speakers
it's gonna be bluetooth wireless it's
not just shirts look the best part is
when i when when people
send me videos and saying hey pat look
i'm in germany i ran into another
valuetainer
wearing a valley team shirt hey pat i'm
in japan i ran into another it's the
best story
that's the best story and you gotta have
good gear because you want people to
want we got some real cool because when
you put on the
the i mean i've seen you wear your
valuetainment shirts and i am an
entrepreneur yeah
right obviously i've been indoctrinated
over the last six months but when you
put that shirt on
like what are what do you feel what are
the people going to feel when you're
when you're going
the reason why mario got the
valuetainment logo tattooed on his hand
on his arm
straight up it's because that's got a
story behind it well people will realize
very soon when you wear that you're
representing capitalism
entrepreneurship free thinkers somebody
that can't be bullied when you wear that
logo you're representing something
people know what that logo stands for
it's very simple
you're independent you're a hard worker
you believe in capitalism you believe in
creativity you believe in innovation
and we want more people sporting that
who believe in that concept and there's
a lot of them right now worldwide who do
so uh i again i can't wait for that once
we launch it
davon himself asked can you do something
you gave a hundred dollars sometimes you
can't
do some sign murders you know what we're
gonna be doing why don't we think about
some sign
yes why don't we think about some sign
and that's also the reason why they need
to go sign up uh and
and register with the link because there
will also be limited merch uh so to make
sure they get the notification
that is one thing ross ross did say
we're not going to have as much as
people want so if they don't order it's
done because
a lot of it's going to be limited supply
with sizes correct so do they need to go
to vtposvtstore.com
forward slash vt uh no btstored.com
that's it
store.com can you put the link up so we
can see what it looks like just put it
up so we can see it
vt stores
why don't you just put it up so we can
all see it
dot com no not not not like that
buddy.com can you use bitcoin to buy
that's actually good go
up go up yeah register yeah and then
they'll be
you're gonna get a lot of news first by
the way can we change that shirt because
that's
we're not even selling that shirt it's
going to be a whole different gear being
sold there can you make sure that's
changed asap so people see it but go
subscribe
there you'll be on the limited list of
people that will send a merge to because
we kind of got to get an idea on how
many people we have on that okay
kyle what were you gonna say bud oh
there you go good wow yeah so you it's
like
some sick there you go just updated yes
some
real sick gear that we have what is this
that's a bluetooth speaker oh cool yeah
you literally set it up you play the
music and it's got a speaker
sounds good they do they do one thing i
don't see on there is the valuetainment
backpack
which is which is insane that one is
really sick
mario does not like free stuff but he
took the water bottle
and the backpack you love that i paid
for it
he did not pay [ __ ] for that we got 17
minutes i want to go through a couple of
the topics so here we go moderna with a
94.5
efficacy uh vaccine coming out amid
breaking reports monday
morning the modernist coronavirus
vaccine candidate reached 94.5
efficacy rate according to a company
announcement many are comparing the
vaccine to pfizer candidate
announced just last monday 90
the founder the founder one of the
things i love is the fact that a lot of
people this past week you know they
weren't paying attention to what's going
on with armenia people are just kind of
glossing over it
but what people don't know is modernist
founder is armenian
nubar afeyan founder of the flagship
pioneering vc is also the board member
of moderna not seo board member but his
company
helped found moderna right after
moderna announced 94.5 efficacy rate
you know what pfizer did the next minute
they said oh we're no longer 90
we're now 95 so what are your thoughts i
don't like it i don't find it funny i'm
offended by it i i have a problem with
it to be honest with you because right
now
we're talking about shutting down the
entire country and all the ramifications
that go with that
the silver bullet is this vaccine that's
supposed to help let's take it a little
bit more seriously okay it sounds like
like a couple elementary kids arguing
whose dad is tougher
i mean give me a break i mean when you
come out a day
after modernist says they're 94.5 and
say oh by the way
we're 95 just so they can sound a little
bit better i don't like it i wish there
was more
uh people that were offended by it like
me this is the most important thing in
the country right now to get us back to
normal
have some respect for the vaccine that's
all i'm telling you
you two rival drug companies by the way
how are they competing with each other i
mean am i going to
amazon.com now to buy my vaccine and i
will be able to choose between pfizer
and moderna is it a marketing battle
between these two
how about we just give some respect to
donald trump
through warp speed operation warp speed
that is getting this thing done so
quickly so we can hopefully get this
country back to normal
kudos to both of these companies i mean
i'm not i don't i don't
you're assuming that there's some fun
and games going on here and then i'm at
94.5 i'm at 95. i'm at 95. i'm not going
to bad optics man i don't know i'm just
saying i'm hoping they're both at
freaking 100 percent no no no no no no
no but
wait for somebody to say where you said
90 a week ago
okay then modernist says 94 5 then a
minute later you say oh we're at 95 now
maybe they're improving i don't know who
maybe is watching too much of boogie
nights with dirk diggler and one guy
said
what do you bench 180 what do you bench
185 what do you squat 220 what are you
scratching i thought you were going
someplace else
no no no pfizer's watching way too much
boogie nights
i'm just hoping that there that this
isn't an elementary
game and there's actually i assume again
some science behind this
and that they actually are 95 because
they probably had to [ __ ]
show the 95 results they're not just
saying it
so we'll see if they actually have the
results we'll see i hope for
everyone's sake they are both at 100
percent
in the next week or two or a month
whatever it comes down to i'm hoping by
the end of the year we do have a vaccine
nothing is that's ready to get out 100
buddy
they're not going to get to 900 just so
you know that but what can they get to
that's like yesterday when you said 100
trump's not gonna win okay
trump's done trump's done and by the way
what did he say he said 100 trump
doesn't stand a chance
right is it 99 percent i said i'm not
betting on it
do you know how much money people owe me
that haven't paid me yet let me ask you
what about 10 let me let me ask you let
me ask you a question
but i got a question tom was at 28
percent this guy said 35
i mean so here's mom's living in fantasy
land over here you think donald
trump is gonna be the problem we had a
conversation the conversation was
conversation was uh uh what are the
chances of uh
uh you know sydney powell rudy giuliani
the attorneys to be able to prove that
trump is still attorney
still as president right uh a time went
from what 28 percent to what
33 33 what's higher what is mine you've
been sticking at five percent i'm about
500 but what's yours
i'm at 0.00 so zero so watch this
so i yesterday offered a bet i said if
you're one hundred percent
that he's not going to why don't we make
a bet yeah
ten thousand two hundred dollars no
that's i lose that ten thousand to one
dollar
let's do ten thousand two hundred
dollars that means if if
you're a hundred percent i don't need
the hundred bucks that's not bad bro oh
by the way
let me ask you this once trump is gonna
go off i got ten g's coming up how about
a hundred pounds make that money and my
barbecue love well wait a minute wait a
minute
how about a hundred thousand no okay so
let me ask you differently
here's the other bet for you yeah okay
what are the chances of you yeah adam
nothing wrong with that what are the
chances of you kissing a man one day
again is is mario included in this or no
he is
i don't know what's the chances honestly
less than zero percent
okay are you willing to bet on it how
much you bet
you will hate to let me ask you a
question let me ask you do you
understand what i'm saying how much do
you bench
easy what do you think do you see what
he's doing he's do you understand what
just happened here
so he said he says 100 he said 100
so you're willing to bet there's no way
for the rest of your life you're ever
going to
kiss a grown man in the lips again
where's mario at let's see where he's at
i'm good i i like ladies you are so
funny even though i'm a soy boy i do
like you you are so
funny but what do you bench though pat i
have no idea
i could probably bench three plates
right now what is that number three
three
or five or three fifteen you how much
three two twenty five plus ninety three
three fifteen
three fifteen yeah i could bench three i
benched three sixteen i can't see i
believe you what's up
that makes sense you watch a lot of
boogie nights yeah
you watch a lot of books it's not for
the
remember one thing about this vaccine
it's not one shot you just don't go get
the shot and you're done yeah
yeah yeah it's it's two shots uh it's
two shots that we got
by the way you know what i forgot to do
so i got all these gifts for matt
it was his birthday october 31 i got him
a mccallum bottle i got him all these
cigars i was supposed to give it to him
when he was here i totally forgot the
cigars are sitting over here matt if
you're watching this buddy i got to send
you a gift i got you a gift
and i haven't given it to you it's been
sitting here for a couple weeks mario
can you make sure z
sends those gifts the bottle and the
cigars over to
uh uh to to matt because it's jennifer
brought it and just remember she
remembers to send that over
again matt man i totally forgot to do
that with matt but we'll do it
okay so let's see what we got last time
airbnb
you want to go airbnb i don't know we
could touch it real quickly you want to
go for it why don't you leave it with
airbnb go yeah okay so they're going
public
um they have an ipo coming up and the
their revenue has dropped 72 percent up
up until june their last
uh filings their revenue was down 72
this ipo is gonna have them valued at
30b
30 billion you know what i don't like
airbnb i don't like the idea of going
into somebody else's house
i think it's weird i think it's creepy
um i
you know if you dig a little bit deeper
on this story the one of the reasons
they're going
to the ipo is because they had promised
a lot of their executives their stock
options and they're going to expire at
the end of the year or
you know six months or whatever so
that's kind of leading the way so some
of these initial guys that have worked
for a b and b
can get out and make their money same
thing and plus they've been borrowing
a ton of money lately just to keep
afloat i think
it's a bad business model i don't think
going forward
people want to stay in other people's
houses i've looked at airbnb online
i don't like it i mean you're looking at
these rooms they're creepy i mean
it makes no sense have you ever stayed
in airbnb i think i have one time i have
one time
it wasn't a great experience i i prefer
hotels nice hotels by the way
and here's my last thought on this um
adam take it from here no you were you
were killing it you're
gonna say something or no i think i got
distracted i was thinking about
something else
uh oh yeah here's my last thought i mean
it makes you think that these
ipos are just rigged for the investment
bankers
and the people that have access to get
in on it to make money it's not so much
that they think
this is a huge play for the future
period
um yeah i i've used airbnb
i've i've been i've done it in london
i've done it in paris i've done it in
rome i've done it in amsterdam i've done
it in new york no we're asking
we're asking where you've stayed at not
who you've done where hey
you said you've done it and all these
things it's a family show here i've done
it in all these places
well that's so that's probably have you
used airbnb yeah well yeah
hello okay got it yes i've stayed in
airbnb for some of us english is literal
you know we think when you say done
let me tell you something um adam
bragging about mario adam's bragging
about every single time he has to brag
about the women in his life there's my
boyfriend mario
he would kiss mario he just said his
specifically said i wouldn't not put
money on that the guy's very uh
enticing but i'll give you an example i
mean we
obviously i know tom is not a fan of
airbnb
but there's millions and millions of
people who are using airbnb i'll give
you a case example we know where a shout
out to the big
biz doc who used to do case examples i
went to amsterdam i was with a
girlfriend of mine at the time
and a buddy of mine is like i'm getting
a hotel it was 400 bucks a night
for a very decent hotel
very just decent hotel you had a little
shoe box
i was with me and my girl for like 200
bucks a night we had a sick
apartment in amsterdam sick half the
price
two bedroom ridiculous spot there was
nothing creepy going on
it was like it was just a dope spot so
if you can save money and stay in a
better spot
a lot of this isn't like five years ago
or just like
you know i don't know what's good like
they got made service that coming in
there
there's people who do this very
professionally so you can
what happens is like just like in amazon
you can see this is a five-star rating
this is a four and a half star
this is a two-star all right if it's a
two-star ain't staying there but if it
has a
four-star four and a half star rating
the place is
do they sick and you can get it for half
the price of what a hotel here's here's
my biggest problem with it you know you
get on a plane right now and you get
these people that take out their wet
wipes and they they wipe everything down
you know the tray table the whole thing
how are people feeling comfortable going
into somebody's house
now in covet i think it's a terrible
idea for the ipo for this country just
may or for this company
it just makes me think that's what it is
isn't that the exact same thing of being
in a hotel room
like there's multiple multiple multiple
people being in a hotel much different
the cleaning staffs in the hotel
but they but my point is they do have
cleaning staff at airbnbs
i know they might there's so but it's so
many people that can
go on airbnb and have their house rented
out right there's only one person at a
time in a hotel you can have dozens and
different random people
if you're going to hotel that hotels you
like you could have literally a hundred
different people staying in a hotel
in that same bed in a given month but an
airborne
property between each one you don't know
you're not listening they have made
service and they have their they have
cleaning services that come in and clean
the airbnbs
and this is why they have ratings just
like you go in a hotel like i'm a big
fan of hotels.com you go on hotels.com
you can see all right i'm gonna get this
hotel
oh this is a five-star hotel sick i get
a good deal oh it's a two-star hotel i'm
out i'm not staying there
so airbnb has seen what the hotel
industry has done they've stepped their
game up
this is clearly why people millions of
people all across the world
embrace airbnb i think airbnb is here to
stay yeah so
you guys can hash it out on what you
want to stay when we travel next time
but uh
airbnb tom won't be staying anywhere tom
you're going to be sleeping in a hotel
bed that literally
is shonda comfortable with airbnb or no
are you guys on the same page with that
no she's very comfortable with the
luxury hotel okay god yeah all right so
she's
you got something i'm comfortable with
what shonda says we're staying tom says
when it comes to travel i call the shots
there oh that very good that's
respectful okay so
uh airbnb brought in 2.5 billion in
revenue in the first
nine nine months of the year this year
down from 3.7 billion
last year so they're down 1.2 billion
they took a hit
uh it's net loss more than doubled
during the period to
697 net loss net loss 697
and they're going at a valuation of what
30 billion dollars you're talking about
10 times their top line
12 times their top line revenue not even
12 times their net profit
they're not even profiting and they're
going at a 30 billion dollar valuation
marketplace this tells you
the public market right now is
interesting when people are going out
there and from the june 30th in a
three-month period their revenues
dropped 72 percent so
the market apparently is saying look we
don't care if you're not making any
money or not we're still willing to
value this thing at a
30 billion dollars and if they can get
away with that and do it look more power
to them if they're going to get it where
people are willing to buy their shares
at a price
like that more power to them i just
think right now uh
i don't see that business model doing
too well anytime
soon but again we'll see what's going to
take place with airbnb
uh and their numbers there honestly
during a pandemic places things like i
mean the hotels are getting crushed it's
not like
they're killing these they're getting
cameras it's not like the airline
industry is doing well none of these
industries are doing well right now by
the way you may have a pandemic you
mentioned biz dock and amsterdam
bisdog probably knows more about the
products that people use freely in
amsterdam than anybody you've ever met
in your life you could do a case study
on weed
like no other from the professor
standpoint
shout out to our buddy there with uh his
math was off in pennsylvania but we'll
cut them away
he's like there's one he's not going
through man it wasn't off on
pennsylvania something happened that
night when we went to sleep we don't
know what happened
they called counting the votes we don't
know what happened that night
happened they counted was on one side
apparently a hundred percent of the
votes that canada was on one side but we
will find out here soon anyways gang if
you enjoyed this show hit that subscribe
button and the alert button
and uh stay tuned we will be back again
next tuesday are we doing it again next
tuesday
uh uh he brought some of the products
adam real quick let's show some of this
stuff before we leave
for some of you that are still here here
we got this one so this is one
this is really cool these are the
headphones that they get the wireless
headphones
yep we got some real cool battery pack
this is one that's a battery charger
with
a free speaker so you charge your phone
and at the same time you're listening to
music
and then we got the presentation folder
that you have with the valuetainment
logon there's the signature
right here this is the blue i use this
thing you set it next
and by the way it's it's heavy if you
feel it it's heavy you can put it
anywhere
uh i'll link your phone to it play your
spotify player podcast listen to our
podcast listen to any music you want
mini bluetooth limited merch will be
launching
next week on black friday
uh first come first serve and we'll
announce it again next week but uh
go to vt stores dot again vtstores.com
subscribe to the newsletter
so you're one of the ones we send the
information to to get this limited merch
that we're launching
next friday having said that gank have a
wonderful weekend everybody
we'll do this again next tuesday take
care everyone bye wednesday next
wednesday
wednesday or tuesday wednesday oh
thanksgiving so we're doing next
wednesday next wednesday
not tuesday bye
you